the far-left could get their wish in
defunding the police this time in the
nation's biggest city protesters outside
City Hall ahead of a vote that will cut
or transfer 1 billion dollars from the
NYPD it comes during a surge in violent
crime but mayor de Blasio back in the
move my office presented to the City
Council a plan that would achieve a
billion dollars in savings for the NYPD
and shift resources to young people to
communities in a way that would help
address a lot of the underlying issues
all right now so we're in our B block
and I have phone-a-friend
you know I phone a friend from Jesse
Watters he has sent me a note and he
said Donna he heard you talking trash so
it's not that he can't hear and that he
is doing his best to make it on air it's
just a technical difficulty we're
working on it and we'll hopefully get
maybe Jesse sent me another text and I
will read it on air Kennedy I want to go
to you about this issue in terms of
defunding the police and you're a mom
you live in the city and I wonder what
you're feeling right now as the crime
rates in the city continue to skyrocket
a majority of New Yorkers people who
live in the five boroughs of New York
City they do not want to defund the
police they they actually have good
interactions with NYPD and by and large
they want that institution to stay
intact the problem with mayor de Blasio
is he's a commie he's talking he's using
the word redistribution like a shameful
pinko and what's going to happen here
and and this is what's so awful is
they're going to demoralize the
department so badly you're not going to
have necessary of philosophical changes
needed for true police reform what's
going to happen is you're going to have
more officers leaving the department
going to different departments we're
leaving the profession entirely crime is
going to go up and then you're going to
see unfortunately a mass exodus of
people who now because of the pandemic
can work from home and they don't want
to pay exorbitant taxes that are going
to programs that are toothless and
totally under serving
damn Bungie no you served in the NYPD
they're facing a vote here at 6:00 p.m.
we're a billion dollars would be taken
away except it sounds like it's also
even just symbolic that actually they
wouldn't really take the money away they
just would say that there they will and
that that supposedly is going to solve
things well one of the it's it's not all
symbolic one of the tenets of this was
the removal of a thousand people from a
recruit class a thousand cops I mean put
that in perspective I think the entire
county I live in in Florida probably
only has two hundred or maybe three
hundred cops I'm not even sure you're
gonna remove a thousand from one class
now Dana
it's not like we haven't been here
before I feel like a candle you ever
read comic books like they had bizarro
Superman when you were a kid where
everything is backwards or remember the
Seinfeld episode when George does
everything backwards and it works out
well this isn't that way George does
everything backwards and nothing will
work out okay we've already been here in
New York anyone remember Ed Koch or
David Dinkins yeah David Dinkins when
thousands of people were murdered on the
streets of New York City and he lost his
election to a Republican in a two to one
New York City Democrats a Republican
Enclave and in Giuliani wins reelection
of a Ruth Messinger by 17 points in New
York City it's because people had enough
Dana not surprisingly of things like
getting killed
that's not a sales pitch for your city
we've been here de Blasio's go in there
again and one more quick thing it's not
just the loss of recruits and the
defunding of the police getting rid of
the anti-crime unit the plainclothes
police units will be the single most
catastrophic decision you've seen yet
you're already seeing murders spike I
mean it's beyond the scope of this
conversation but I'll explain why maybe
at another show some time but
devastatingly bad decision
Donna Joe Biden has said he does not
believe in defunding the police and
they're in NYPD you actually have I
think 60% of the police officers are
non-white the fact that you have people
demoralized wanting to be police
officers and now you have a thousand
recruits that can't even get trained in
order to become police officers
eventually why wouldn't somebody like
Bill
or the Democrats say instead of taking
money from the police why don't we add
money for additional support if they
want to add social workers or programs
for children like maybe isn't that a
better way to approach this for
Democrats and instead you know you're
facing a situation where people are
going to say they're not for this well
Dan as you well know all all across the
country not just in big cities small
cities many city councils as well as
mirrors are taking a look at their
overall budget they are in a budget
shortfall given the money that has been
spent to on covet and trying to prevent
the spread and so what these police
departments are doing at this hour is
not just looking at the role of the
police departments but also looking at
how to how to decriminalize some of
these things that the police departments
are doing they're reallocating funding
funding they're reimagine what the
police department should look like in
the 21st century I applaud all of the
mayors and City Council's that are
taking a look at their budgets taking a
look at what they're going to do here in
the District of Columbia the mayor is
talking about adding to it if you look
at overall over the last 10 years you've
seen a 14 15 percent increase in
policing because police are increased
for the police right that's right
increase because policemen and by the
way I have policemen in my family
they're called to do everything they're
called to handle the domestics disputes
their call went home yesterday I
followed fall asleep on the park bench
they're called to do everything so
they're looking at ways to put resources
and other city budgets that may also
contribute to public safety and
preventing crimes and not just funding
the pleasure alone you want to say and
if you don't mind so the former NYPD
Commissioner Ray Kelly he was on earlier
with obviously he oversaw the police
department at a time when crime was down
now is going up take a listen
the NYPD or the city is surrendering as
far as the violent crime is concerned I
put this all at the feet of mayor de
Blasio he's the one that's made these
decisions he
that's the strength of the NYPD's since
he took office in 2014 Dan one of the
things that de Blasio said today was
that even though he sees the crime rates
going way up he still thinks he can
manage to keep the city safe even if
they cut a billion dollars from the NYPD
yeah but Dana he's not you know I said
yesterday dude we believe in facts and
data is anybody doing that anymore are
we just in a post fact Society shootings
are up dramatically
police retirements are up dramatically
cops are coming off the street assault
auto crimes everything is up I mean does
that even matter and if I just on it
with all due respect I just wanted
challenge do you think you know you said
about the budget cuts I agree with you
budget cuts are gonna have to have to
happen sadly everywhere I totally agree
with you and even the police department
gonna have to look at a way to find
efficiencies but you don't cut a billion
dollars from the PD and a hierarchy of
needs you may want to consider other
cuts before security and secondly I
can't do the reimagine the police line
anymore
I'm serious every single Democrat on
television uses this line we don't have
to reimagine policing we did it in the
early 90s it was called broken windows
and literally tens of thousands of lives
in largely minority communities in New
York City were safe there are people
alive today because we implemented and
actually reimagine policing that seems
to be important to avoid of any tactics
da da Dan if we're gonna try to reform
the police department where they
continue use excessive force if they
continue to not be properly trained if
they continue to kill innocent people
Dan so to reimagine they're reforming so
that people are not afraid of police
officers who are paid to protect and
serve the citizens I think we both agree
that we should respect our men and women
the police department but they should
understand that they serve the community
and I think what is coming out of the
movement that we've seen across the
country it's that we want a police
department that serves the community and
not scared
Kennedy has the last word here because
what really is frustrating about this
past month and a half is that there is a
lot of agreement there's a lot of
agreement and you say oh yeah you could
you could solve these problems pretty
easily if you took the politics out of
it Kennedy yes absolutely and and
essentially because Dan and Don are
actually saying some of the same things
and when you talk about reimagining the
police department you're not necessarily
saying get rid of the police and I think
everyone agrees that we asked too much
of men and women in law enforcement we
do ask them to be social workers we ask
them to be domestic referees we ask them
to save our lives we want to be able to
call them when our safety is in jeopardy
but Dan unfortunately it doesn't work
flawlessly and seamlessly in every
department and there are certain things
and there are certain lists we could
make about no-knock warrants and in
mandatory body cams and qualified
immunity and those rats don't seriously
want to get rid of qualified immunity do
you I mean do you understand Lisa come
on if you get rid of qualified immunity
give me a break you're a police officer
hyperbole because that type of hyperbole
doesn't solve the problems that we have
thank you and and wearing blinders and
saying policing is perfect that also
does warn you it I actually do the job I
don't think you sign that I understand
that and so did it like Donna I have
family members in law enforcement I love
them they're the kind of cops that I
want on the street there are bad cops
out there who do bad things and we do
have to make sure there is more
accountability thank you all right